so as shel introduced I'm a professor
assistant professor in HCI Institute I
had joined in 2017 after I graduated
also I'm a courtesy professor in both
mechanical engineering and also material
science and engineering at CMU is kind
of relevant to my talk today because you
will soon noticed a lot of the work I
showed need need interdisciplinary
knowledge is from all the different
fields so the lab is called Marshall
matter lab and the way Y morphing matter
from FCI perspective since Douglas
opened and initiated this whole field of
graphic interface we started to discuss
what is the more natural and intuitive
way to represent information firstly
represent them on the screen and then
later do videos computing him out and
group of pioneers started to wonder how
we can bring digital information even
more intuitive bring it out of the
computer screen and back to our daily
life through the embedded embedded
tangible interfaces and among all these
pioneers were trying very hard to make
interface more and more intuitive one of
those is my amazing advisor a PhD
advisor professor here she she so he has
a research group over MIT Media Lab
tangible media group and he has been
really leading us to think about what
are the possible kind of ways to design
more tangible and more physical
interfaces to with computation into our
daily life he and Shawn and many other
of his few students have been worked
very actively bringing active objects
and dynamic shape-changing interfaces to
to represent information and after I
joined his group I was thinking well all
these interfaces are amazing but
eventually if you look at this magical
shape tuning display there is a gigantic
master
microcontroller based mechanism behind
the magic and eventually when we talk
about physical computation so we look
into how nature works how our human body
works right it functions it actually
responds to an environment even change
color and shape and being adaptive it is
a natural interface but it does not
require such sophisticated electronic
power control system so I started to
wonder how we can learn from our how our
body function and how natural interface
how natural natural organism function
and try to find a branch to talk about a
sub-branch to talk about Hendra
interfaces that's that's where active
materials were born and we kept working
on it and now it concluded as a thread
of work called morphing matter that's
why mark marginal matter exists and we
cannot talk about more from matter
without talking about nature so these
are the pine trees I grew up with them
so I was from Inner Mongolia after rain
I will run to the forest to pick up
pinecones and mushroom as well so as a
kid I realized even for this little pine
cone after rain it's fully closed when
you pick them up on the floor but you
put it on the balcony for a cup of days
the other scales will open up and the
magical part is you put it back in water
you close again so soon I realized after
I had joined MIT so there were a bunch
of science papers talk about this
interesting mechanism it is a smart
material in a sense is very similar to
the kind of active shape changing
mechanism here is group has been really
pursuing but this is powered by nature
so there's no electronic components is
completely green and and the
transformation behaviors are completely
completely powered by the material
itself and also the environmental
condition but it is the interface
because the pinecone is responding to
the rain and behave in a certain way for
the seed actually dispersal
innocence is an interface for for the
life to survive itself and it got really
fascinated by these kind of natural
organisms and started to draw a table
and try to summarize all the magical
transformations that can happen in
nature and powered without using
electricity so you can see it ranges
from the very simple bending motion to
sophisticated coiling and volumetric
expansion and contraction again they are
doing all these magical behaviors for
four very different purposes mostly for
survival and we carefully study those
natural organisms and start to develop
more synthetic versions of those
material so in our lab we have a heavy
emphasis on the material development
mostly inspired by nature and in order
to tailor these materials to have
specific compositions and structure we
also are very very into developing
hardware and software design tools to
build up the hierarchical transformation
heavier of the material and that we
really care about design applications
and I think part of the fun to begin the
field of HCI is because we get to really
imagine what what's what the future
could be it was the future of life could
be so we wanted to bring those active
materials into our daily life from all
the way fabric to robots to lampshade
and to even food so today I will bring
three projects that I was involved
across the past a few years and three
daily materials and I will see I will
introduce how we are bringing this kind
of magical morphing behavior to these
three daily materials paper food and
fashion so I will start with a very
recent project it's called printed paper
actuator and we love paper so artists
love paper too so there are many ways
you can manipulate paper to give it
interesting properties for design
in cutting joy in printing and animating
so in this project we are looking into
another functionalities or
characteristics we can bring to paper
that's its transformation behavior it's
very simple three steps first we use
this commercially available printing
filament it is a graphene PLA composite
and just directly printed on top of a
paper so it's a very cheap filament but
it has a magical behavior that's it's a
shape memory shape memory behavior
indeed so this is what we printed you
can see it's a really thin layer of this
conductive filament and the paper
substrate and this is a treating process
as the second step you put it in an oven
you heat it up to a certain temperature
it bends up and reach a maximum bending
angle it's like a treating process and
then now the people are actuator is
ready to go so you give it current it
become flat and then you you you cut off
the current and then it bends again and
this is reversible just like how the
pine cone works and then the power of
design comes in you can start to think
about what are the interesting patterns
you can design with this animated paper
structure you can make different folding
mechanisms and you can also design
different mat you can use different
construction methods so for example you
can make a spiral turn turns into a
circle or you can make these kirigami
structures basically from a flat sheets
how how things can pop up like how
pop-up books would work you can also
design different functional properties
into paper so this is an elastic
property we were looking into how to
make the elastic robotic legs with this
paper origami or premiere ability change
through the structural design and you
can also utilize the functionality that
this filament being conductive to create
sensors simple sensors like sliding
sensing or touch sensing to
interesting sensor like self angle
sensing etc and we can make for example
some robotic toys it's all very very
simple to make you just design the basic
stripes and combine them in different
way to get different different
higher-level form factors this is is
this is another example of the
caterpillar robots and you can also make
synthetic plants it responds to your
touch people may know this plant called
mimosa behaves in a very similar ways
and natural plants if you touch it or if
you hit it it'll transform this is just
a little animated pop-up and you can
also if you are industrial designer and
love physical artifacts you can make a
lampshade when you turn it on by sliding
through this little stripe the the the
patented light can change in real time
this is my favorite by the way it's just
poetic think about as a little kid you
draw things on a piece of paper but now
you draw things what with with a pen but
whatever you draw we can become animated
right away and some of my students
brought this technique to a to a to a
design college this summer and they run
a workshop but with the topic what is a
book
with this printed paper actuators so
these are some of the outcomes from the
from the from the workshop so for me
it's just really interested
interesting to see how a simple
technology with some smart design can
bring a lot of magic to empower
designers who think about graphic design
from a very different perspective
[Music]
so in the lab with sometimes work on
really tricky materials you need to use
very sophisticated
for example fabrication machines to make
nano structure but we are also super
interested in investigating why did
accessible material there is a power in
terms of using very available materials
to empower more people to be able to
explore it this is one of these examples
they have to definitely have that
democratizing aspects and I wanted to
draw a beautiful lesson to share with
you guys in terms of how to engineer
different materials to have this
morphing behavior so you really we have
three secret ingredients
the first is stimuli people are asking
you're not using electricity necessarily
what could be the stimulus as long as
you want things to move you need energy
if it's not electricity it must be
something else
ring or temperature fluctuations so
stimuli is an important component and
also composition remember I showed you
guys a lot of interesting origami
structures we engineered we are very
very interested in investigating
hierarchical structure design when we
engineer different transformation and
also of course we cares about the
property that you last he city the
premiere ability we are bringing through
the transformation is kind of the design
goal so we kept this in mind whenever we
engineer different materials so take
this paper actuator as an example the
stimuli is the heat in this case is
resistive resistive heating the
composition is the way we are printing
different patterns on top of the paper
and the property is the bending is the
bending primitives that we are able to
engineer and this is a universal lesson
I share with my students regardless the
material they are looking into and it's
widely adapt to adaptable to different
contexts as well for example when my
grandma make a big balloon inflated the
bread you know kitchen she is also using
the similar principle there's energy
coming from the
hot oil and then there is this Express
expansion energy cost the transformation
with the purpose of shape changing bread
in this case and she also tells me when
the dumplings are floating on top of
water
it means the dumpling is done so in this
case think about it it is water as
energy to cost the inner expansion of a
piece of dumpling and the goal of the
dumpling floating on top is because the
dumpling wants to tell you hey I'm ready
if dumpling becomes an interface so just
fascinating to think how how you can
expand the interpretation of interface
once you started to look into the
physical media or the physical materials
so that's really brought us to think
about kitchen as a possible context to
explore morphing matter if you think
about the kitchen
mmm we we have different types of
stimulus when you are cooking food right
you're frying baking you're boiling and
we have many many properties we really
care or we want it to go very geeky to
manipulate including flavors shape the
crunchiness the surface texture of your
croissant and from material scientists
this is a really interesting context and
for interface designer as well that
really brought us actually a bunch of
PhDs from both MIT and currently at
Carnegie Mellon to cook and I will
introduce a second project called
transformative appetite and I started to
work on it with a lot of my
collaborators back at MIT and we are
broadly we're bringing it to CMU as well
for further development so apparently
there is a long history for people that
manipulates the physical properties of
food and call them interfaces all the
way from color change to texture changes
and we are looking into a very
interesting property called or actually
indeed also very very widely observable
property called the hydration property
of material so this is a piece of starch
when you put it in water the starch will
swell and cause the change of
of its volume everybody knows about it
we who cook a piece of pasta so the past
I will grow fatter that's what's going
on and that's the phenomenon we are
looking into so if you go a little bit
deeper to understand all kind of
different edible components that your
food are made of you can think about
agar gelatin starch cellulose and all of
these ingredients to some extent absorb
water and hydrate but they have a
different hydration rate and now we can
do something interesting so if you put a
piece of edible sheets but then you
print another edible material but has a
different swelling rate and you can
engineer a flat piece of food but once
you cook them in water the it starts to
bend so again it's a pine cone and this
is just a scanning electron microscopic
images to show you how the density
actually varies for the food sample we
made and this is again a microscopic
image you see the center part of the
food grow much slower than the edges
that's because the center part is made
of cellulose and gelatin composite while
the edges are purely made of gelatin you
can out play this again so if you pay
attention this this the center part res
is much slower than the edge this by the
way is exactly how nature taught us to
do the pinecone can open up you know
very specific curvature is all because
nature grows its composition in a very
particular way and you can go to
something fancier so now if you try to
make a more complex composite with the
cellulose printed on top of the
composite you can engineer with more
complex behavior for example you can
transform a disc into a potato chip
shape it once you cook them and you can
go even more sophisticated to control
the composition ratio of the cellulose
and gelatin to get different different
degrees of shadow shadow shaping in this
case and you can make a flattest turn
into a flower as well as you cook it
so I will explain a little bit of the
fabrication process behind this project
[Music]
so we envisioned the idea of
shape-changing pasta and in this case we
prepared a flat film that's made of
gelatin it's a gel and then we 3d
printed two different two different
healed cellulose lines on top of the
gelatine film we prepared beforehand
this is just a software to help you
simulate if you combine the cellulose
and the gelatine film in different way
what are the possible shapes you can get
and these are the real pasta as you cook
them they start as flat after 10 minutes
they take on different shape I said
pasta with quotation because they are
made of gelatin and cellulose they taste
like jello crunchy jell-o's but anyway
so you can see there are a lot of shapes
you can you can self-assemble and some
of them look like a traditional pasta
but some of them are actually very hard
to make if you use conventional pasta
manufacturing technique and by the time
when we were working on this project
with target we really we really were
trying to push the concept that this
will save their packaging space so we
did a sophisticated calculation to show
how much packaging space you can save if
you make all your pasta flat and we
ended up working with the French cuisine
chef over Boston it's called espalier
and it's one of the fanciest French
cuisine restaurant in Boston area so he
put some of the customized flavor into
our shape changing
he rose and made for example mushroom
flowers and squid ink paste
coiled shape and he also played it
plated some of the dishes we were very
interested in introducing these shape
changing performances in real time in a
fine dining context
it's amazing to see he basically is
played with our material and came out
with all the dishes almost on the flight
it's a video shot purposely but really
he didn't do any rehearsals this is my
favorite by the way it's a flat film if
you put it in to water it will wrap all
the caviar around it and form a little
rap so my original motivation to work on
this project is shape-changing actually
self-folding dumplings because every
time i go home and mom will spend hours
and hours to make me dumplings this is
just a but dumplings are really hard to
make so this is just a one step towards
they'll something and this is
another really interesting one so it's a
noodle if you cook it for a shorter time
it stays long but if you cook them for
longer it will self chop into a smaller
pieces you matter you can cook both for
yourself we like long noodles for
texture and your kids who like shorter
ones for easier digestion within one pot
so again talk back about the interfaces
when I gonna film wrap things around it
when a pasta can be its own timer and
based on the knees to program is on
shape we are talking about interfaces we
are talking about interfaces that are
pre-programmed with very very different
conditions and specific behaviors and
why why pasta web pasta we heard he
cares about shape manipulation we
sourced all kinds of food around the
globe and realize Italians are super
specific about the shape of pasta will
better demonstrate our powerful shape
changing grammars by looking into pasta
so I ended up visit the perilla really
against everybody knows it's a one of
the biggest Italian pasta manufacturer
in Milan last year and I presented what
we did at MIT and I said hey what if we
collaborate you guys are cool we are
cool we're gonna really make this pasta
into the market although now tastes like
gel I have an idea how to make it taste
like real pasta and I also showed this
diagram it shows specific macaroni pasta
compared to the flat ones can can
actually waste 67 points 3% of the
packaging space and and also if you pack
pasta in 3d shape they are very fragile
they can break very easily and also I
told them this is a great selling point
just for marketing reason and I got them
convinced and we started to sponsor us
and not only with money but also Italian
grown authentic semolina flour and we've
been shaving it many times to our lab
for the past year and and I again I also
showed them you know you not only can
sell this in supermarket but then you
can also put put them into your Barilla
kitchen as fine dining experiences and
potentially gathers to mountain hikers
disaster sites or even space travel in
the future so near the the now are very
convinced they are working with us and
these are the newest newest outcome what
you see here I'm very proud it's real
pasta so they are purely made of
semolina flour and water and the they
are using a completely different
mechanism in terms of transformation we
soon are having a paper out not sure
where it goes but we are targeting more
scientific journal publication and
trying to convince them the
transformation mechanism behind it is
actually more universal but pasta can be
one of those design cases so before it's
a street noodle if you cook it it turns
into a instant noodle with coiled shapes
but you can of course do more
sophisticated things these are just four
examples we we we showed to perilla
actually they're they're researchers
over the Italian headquarter we're able
to replicate all of this and there they
are getting an exclusive licensing from
CMU super exciting so means they are
very serious to get it this into the
market and we are group did a hiking
trip a few months ago and this is a the
leading author on this paper herself
cooking it outdoor and trying to eat
some of this so yeah so it's really a
table now and through this journey of
the past year working with the real
we also figured this is more Universal
than just just cooking sorry then just
being boiled you can also bake it so
these are the sort of Japanese wagashi
flour you make it through baking you can
transform it into 3d it's getting closer
and closer to my dream of self-folding
dumplings for sure and these are again
they are all self assemble the self
assembled food and we try to sell it too
messy and say you know you can make self
self wrapping tacos so these were all
produced flat and if you bake it you
wrap itself and we stuff them afterwards
so yeah so we are getting really excited
again about this project because the
general mechanism we figured is not only
applied to flour but also to hydrogels
to to silicone so we could have wider
usage for health and medical and soft
robots in general as well and if this
mechanism is a cross scale it could
potentially work for nano robots or
micro robots at least so we're working
on that and the last project the big
project I wanted to explain again it
came out of my PhD thesis 2-1 years ago
it's a cod biologic so this way in this
case we are actually transforming the
third type of a material that's a living
material it's a P it's actually a
special bacteria and this is what we
made out of the bacteria hybrid material
[Music]
so this sweat responsive garment is
secretly powered by this specific
bacteria that's only one-tenth the
diameter of your hair is called bacillus
subtilis natto bacteria and it's a very
interesting bacteria because edible and
the rooted itself in a long history of
Japanese samurai so apparently when they
summarize almost ten thousand years a
thousand years ago so they were on a
path who and carried some soybeans you
know dry rice stock made bag and he
tasted the soybean and felt it was much
more tasty than the soybean he used to
taste and lean around the figure that
was because the bacteria hided the
inside this dry rice talk fermented
soybean and so the the Japanese name of
this bacteria actually called dry red
stalk bacteria the direct translation
into English is yes not ona its bacillus
subtilis or natto bacteria so if you go
to Japan nowadays it's a it's a classic
breakfast you you get this soil being
super sticky and if you put this under
microscope actually they are full of
bacterias like that this is a microscope
image we we we were able to capture so
we are leveraging this asian bacteria
for its new function so we found out
this bacteria can be really sensitive to
the moisture condition in the
environment expand and contract based on
based on the relative humidity so yeah
it's a nano actuator in a sense and if
you deposit thousands or millions of
those nano actuators and the piece of
fabric they started to behave like a
pine cone again so if you if you
increase the relative humidity it
becomes flat and if you decrease the
humidity it burns up and remember my
whole idea of stimuli composition so
here is the composition trick so if you
started to prune the bacteria in
parallel lines in very different ways
you can manipulate the bio-hybrid
material to have different
transformative function in this case
responding to the relative humidity it's
super super sensitive you if you put it
on her skin the little micro moisture
environment around your body can already
actuate this bacteria so we ran to New
Balance and thought here we're finding a
killer app first for your sports garment
we want you to make sweat responsive
garment New Balance head color was a
about half an hour away drive from MIT
so yeah so they give us a lot of heat
map and also a lot of devices of how to
make fabric composite this is what we
came out so these are two functional
performative fabric made garment and
they responds to your body condition mmm
so when you are when you are when you
are dry and code all the scales on the
back of your body will close and when
you get sweaty and hot all the flaps
will open up its self tunable again it's
a it's an interface and there's a
computational loop but it's happening
within the material he understands the
environment in this case your body
condition and try to tune things in
real-time and responds in real-time it's
just being really fascinating to think
about how you can interpret the whole
idea of action and reaction you know
interface loop from a material
perspective this is a close shot of how
these skills actually look like when
your body is sweating
and this is the process of how we
prepared how we prepared the bacteria
and when I worked on this project I was
always excited by the idea that we are
making actuators but we are making
actuators in a wet lab we are growing
them instead of you know buying
electromagnetic motors in the market or
astringent to customize the stuff for us
and one actuator can plug in 2 billion
overnight so it came as a free energy
this is just a humming force microscope
to image how the bacteria is changing in
its volume as in blowing on how I'm
using a straw blowing breathing on the
bacteria as it as you can observe the
transformation of there and then we load
the bacterial solution we prepared
overnight into a syringe extruder this
is a customized printer to deposit the
bacterias line-by-line
on a piece of elastomeric substrate it's
a silicon substrate safer body you can
wear it and depends on how you are
printing it you can control the
sensitivity of the transformation and
also the geometry of the transformation
so we ended up working with two dancers
from Boston Ballet Company and these
were just the attends piece that we
helped us to shoot and demonstrate how
the bacteria behave
so here we actually integrate the lesson
we learned from New Balance so they gave
us the heat map so all the patterns are
computationally designed to address the
the body part that's easily little sweat
and we tune the sensitivity of the
fabric by controlling the density of the
bacteria and also the thickness of the
bacteria so we make sure you don't get
to tell you
[Music]
yes oh no doubt there are a lot of
engineering work and also there are a
lot of back-and-forth communication
between the fashion designer who design
the government and also the bioengineer
a breeder who are raising the sell but
in general I think it's a really great
lesson to see how the merging of
disciplines can actually inspire both
sides so for example when we started to
work with the dancers the they were all
really professional dancers at that
point but these two said they were so
inspired by the fact that they are
carrying living things on their back and
started to almost create their own dance
movement and we were very inspired by
their comments and decided to make art
exhibition called dancing with billions
of bacteria and you can see their
expressive motions are tailored almost
who to leading to the fact that you know
some things are living so these
exhibitions were curated for the two
sides of almost worldview or the view of
making so the made and the born world
and these are the sculptures we made for
the exhibition and a fun video to
document the exhibition
see my advisor Hiroshi a today in this
video too
so again some bacteria is very hard to
control so there were another
frustration just you know to take pain
them to behave in the way we want and
printer is one way to tame them
basically make their geometric patterns
so we wanted to through this exhibition
to open up the discussion how synthetic
formatic manipulation and natural growth
can can coexist so here you see all
those patterns are very precisely
printed so they behave exactly as how we
predicted in our software but then on
the other side of this exhibition these
are naturally brown Heaven and bacteria
gotta express the way they want so there
is a balance the beauty ml as well and
even the sculpture it's a precisely
wires doctor friend
with this organic
transform in the way they wanted
so it has speakers on the side shoot so
their body and make them transform
[Music]
so later we we thought we should publish
them this this work in more serious
community because we do think the idea
of leveraging a a living bacteria for
the sake of a nano actuation could be
more Universal or could be more
adaptable to a scientific community so
we started to work on this idea of
genetically modified nano actuator if
you use a living bacteria you can
genetically engineer the DNA to put
multi functionality into the bacteria
for example we made a bacteria that
could actuate as well as glow and both
glowing and also actuation respond to
the moisture it was published eventually
at the science advances so the idea is
you can you can yeah again so you can
make a synthetic material piyo hybrid
material that can glow more and more
intensively as it actuate in response to
the increase in moisture so this is the
shoe we made now the shoe can not only
open up to get rid of your sweat but
also a glow as you are running in dark
we yeah this is a close shot of the
glowing bacteria actuator we did an
exhibition later on also at Centre
Pompidou in Paris just to show a glowing
sculpture and since I'm in the school of
computer science and since I am hired by
school senior science nowadays after I
left meteor lab I really wanted to ask
the question of why computer science and
also more and more of my students at CMU
are into the whole idea of computation
behind the physical materials we're
manipulating so I just want you to
quickly give a few examples of the
recent work we are doing which integrate
more of a CS perspective think about a
piece of flour we want it to morph the
flour on the left hand to the flour on
the right hand so it's a basically a
flat piece that can self-assemble into a
rose it's intuitively
feasible but it's getting really hard
for me to compute even at the
experienced Morpher and this turns out
to be the layers and also the specific
angles you need to program into each
hinge and also each pedal that are that
are that are going outwards we started
to see the necessity of developing more
sophisticated design tools for the kind
of materials we are interested in and
the kind of marking behaviors were
interested in thinking if you wanted to
you know self assemble this classic
Stanford bunny what is the inverse
computational pipeline to even to even
design the flat shape to have it self
food back into a Stanford bunny so this
is a tool that we developed and we
publish this work already so if you guys
are interested in you mean replicating
it it's actually quite fun because the
the two is compatible with MakerBot you
can literally do this in your lab and
also desire own shapes as well but not
only origami we are also interested in
double curvature shapes basically those
smooth more organic shapes and they're
getting harder computationally for
example this chair surface we want it to
morph a flat piece into itself assemble
the organic chair surface by the way the
motivation is we want to sell this to
Ikea imagine the furniture the the save
billions of dollars by making flat pack
but then once it's at your home you have
to manually assemble them more beautiful
shapes take more of your time to
assemble so we wanted to make big
furnitures when you plug into the wall
they self assemble into very expressive
shapes on the fly so but in order to
make more organic shapes we need to
think about what what's the inverse
inverse computational algorithms to
enable this to happen so this is one of
the example we publish in waistt last
year 2018 basically you can make each
beam shrink in a very specific ratio and
then you can back calculate the desired
3d shape you will get and this twos are
all tailored to
the final print to pass and what about
an armor and you can again also back
calculate what is the best desired
bending angle or shrinkage ratio for
each beam in order to get the final
shape you want so this is the tool
behind behind what I just showed as
organic shapes I you want a leaf and
then you can input the shape of the leaf
so the software will help you to compute
all the shrinkage ratio needed for each
beam and turn it into print to past and
you can you can export the two paths and
eventually print it out as a flat piece
if you put in water it should it should
morph as what you input it at the very
beginning from the software so reality
is always harder than the imagination it
turns out if it's pure geometric
calculation it never give you them more
the most precise precise prediction
because there are gravities they're
physical material they're getting
software as they transform their
torsional forces you know shearing
everything is affecting the accuracy of
simulation so a group of my students are
working on actually leveraging machine
learning and fun element analysis to
make the simulation more accurate our
big big vision is to be able to design
and simulate morphing structures
regardless of the type of material in
real time to empower everybody to design
the design morphing morphing behaviors
for the contacts that they're interested
in so this is another example we're
going to talk about in KY 2019 this year
this is a play with the dimension we
talked about 2d sheets
transfer me into 3d what about 1v1
design turn into 3d so we are printing
basically you know all those voxel per
voxel combinations of shrinkage
behaviors into a single line and then
you can universally design the shape
adore transforming into as you trigger
them with heat or water oh sorry I need
to go back little bit
yes quite fun to think about the the
limit of the dimensionality you could
decrease for morphing materials and you
can also design different compliant
mechanisms in this case once you
transform them into different shapes you
can start to play with them and it
becomes a little tools and this is
almost at the end of my talk so the
possibilities are limited unlimited I
hope at least that's the one lesson I
hope I managed to share but go back to
the original question and ask again why
Morphin matter why more f---ing matter
so I I've been thinking we can
technically do everything but what makes
sense to spend our lifetime for so I
have this strong belief may be partially
infused by Professor he Russia and all
the pioneers of working with tangible
and the physical medium that no matter
how much advanced advancement we are
getting in terms of the computational
technologies we can never leave our
physical environment and you know you
you you compute and Twitter's and
Twitter's and all the social network we
come become a learning system and adapt
adapt to your needs but if we can also
make a shoe for your daughter and as she
grew older and older the shoe can learn
and adapt to the size and needs and
aesthetic
demands of your daughter so and also you
know no matter how how fast the virtual
reality or you know all the many reality
technology are advancing how fascinated
we are by the idea of living in this
virtual environment you eventually you
after where you go home you sit on a
physical couch we need your physical
food as an interaction designer I think
I'm almost feel
to remind people to not get the physical
physical environment and that's the
beauty of our life but you know also as
a technologist I wanted to make sure I'm
not going back to the ancient life we
wanted to use our knowledge to empower
the imaginations of interfaces
that's why emergent matter should exist
and how to morph matter so if you think
about this whole interdisciplinary
statement for HCI researchers we used to
merge electrical engineering mechanical
engineering Computer Sciences design and
art all together to create HCI research
but with the whole motivation of
engineering merging matter we need to
bring more interdisciplinary
interdiscipline into our radar that
includes material science chemistry
mechanics rate and advanced
manufacturing and computational tools
and human biological engineering we are
very very interested in potentially
using DNA to engineer material
properties at even lower lower scale
actually we are kind of working on that
so if you guys are interested in knowing
more of the possibilities of morphing
matters we're having five papers at Keio
this year 2019 and we we talked about in
my talk paper plastic food and bacteria
as potential marketing matter candidates
and we are bringing more again to our
big family so we are thinking of you
know foam thread hydrogels and silicone
and even 3d knitted goods as potential
candidates for margin matters so I'm
they're interesting thing and also
discussing these projects with with you
guys and I wanted to end my talk with
this inspiring statement from actually
Leonardo da Vinci so in order to make
pure creations that merge technology and
also your imagination and it's important
to think about the integration of
artificial and natural world art and
science reality and fantasy as well as
the experiences and imagination and
I appreciate everybody's time to be here
and this is my amazing team is growing
very rapidly every day I feel
overwhelmed by their creativity and yeah
you guys are welcome to visit us it's a
Pittsburgh thank you
[Applause]